hey guys it's Wednesday January sixth
I'm Mary and this is gamespot news first
up oculus rift revealed not only the
price but the minimum specs today they
are as follows a lot and a lot the
oculus rift based pre-order package
which comes with an xbox one controller
oculus remote a sensor and free copies
of eval curry and Lucky's tale will cost
six hundred dollars the headset starts
shipping on march 28th there's a limit
of one per customer as announced
previously you don't have to pay upfront
to pre-order in oculus only when the
device ships later this year will you be
charged pre-ordering not only gets you a
free copy of a Valkyrie but it also puts
you in front of the line to buy oculus
touch controllers when they arrive the
recommended memory requirements is 8
gigabytes of ram or the processor
recommendation is mid-range intel i5
4590 the graphics card shouldn't be less
powerful than the nvidia gtx 970 or the
AMD are 9290 meanwhile four USB ports
are required for all parts of the
peripheral to work oculus recommends
that three of them are USB 3.0 well
that's a lot of money but if you have
600 extra dollars laying around and you
don't know what to do with it here are
some other options 10 zombie gnome
statues for your garden this 2016 Range
Rover style power wheels i found on
amazon pills that make you [ __ ] actual
gold twenty thirty dollar prostitutes or
one really good one a brand new ps3 also
requires a time machine to go back to
2006 next up xbox one and pc game recore
have been delayed recore the upcoming
adventure game from microsoft and mega
man creator Keiji Inafune a will not
launch the spring as originally planned
a microsoft representative said the game
is now slated to arrive during the
latter half of 2016 although an exact
date wasn't dated just this week
microsoft confirmed that recore will
also launch on pc through windows 10
however whether or not will also come to
steam remain to be seen did that store
and make you sad here's some more [ __ ]
you can buy for six hundred dollars for
bb-8 3.5 ounces of beluga sturgeon
caviar 20 different
hats for cats for iron man sleeping bags
too many crayon bounce houses six
fingerprint gun safes for your six guns
finally it's time to get swifty because
there's a Rick and Morty game coming out
Adult Swim games revealed a new game on
Twitter that seems to be a mix of
Pokemon and Adult Swim's popular show
Rick and Morty this won't be the first
time Rick and Morty have appeared in a
video game in August of last year the
time-travelling duo joined dota 2 as an
announcer pack it was good stuff pocket
Morty's is due to hit iOS and Android on
january fourteenth i choose you tiny
Rick and that's it for me today that
I'll see you again same time tomorrow oh
you want more [ __ ] you can spend 600
bucks on four hammocks for a baby 200
gallons of milk from safeway four of
these 26 pound gummy worm party pythons
Nick's a giant chess set 42 Jeff
Goldblum mugs